[Music]
[Applause]
graduates please be seated
graduates honored guests faculty staff
family and friends welcome to the 2018
graduation ceremony at the Stanford
University Graduate School of Business
I'd like to begin by recognizing the
people around us who have played a
pivotal role in the experience of our
graduates the faculty that sit behind me
have led our students on a
transformative journey could I ask the
faculty to stand for a moment Effects
[Applause]
around the pavilion our staff from the
MBA the MSX and the PhD programs whose
dedication and effort have helped make
the journey meaningful and enjoyable I
ask that our staff stand and be
recognized
for many of you who are graduating your
GSB education has been a team effort
your families and friends have been
there to listen to support you and to
advise you let's take a moment to
recognize our families and friends
now I would like to say a few words to
you our 2018 GSB graduates earlier this
year I read a biography of an American
author Laura Ingalls Wilder now Laura
Ingalls Wilder grew up on the American
frontier in the 19th century and she
went on to write many books about her
experience as a child on the frontier
including Little House on the Prairie
and and and a number of others in that
series and some of you may have read
those books I read them as children and
then I read them to my own children
several times in fact and she lived a
very remarkable life but what struck me
in reading her biography was the way
that the world changed during her
lifetime in 1880 at the age of 12 Laura
Ingalls spent a winter in Dakota
Territory her father worked for the
railroad company the nearest neighbor
was 37 miles away unreachable in winter
snows there was no telegraph
no telephone no postal service no radio
no means of communication her family was
completely isolated she recounted that
winter 50 years later when she became a
writer this was in the 1930s by the time
she wrote about that winter there was
electricity there was indoor plumbing
there was long-distance communication
she drove with her daughter from
Missouri to California and eventually
she flew on an airplane to New York
between the winter that she spent in
Dakota Territory and her death in 1957
standards of living in the United States
more than doubled twice those changes in
a single human life are extraordinary
and they have continued a child who was
born in the year that she died that is
1957 has lived to see the invention of
the transistor genetic sequencing access
to information become instantaneous life
expectancy which was 37 years in 1880
increased to 80 years and billions of
people around the world lifted from
poverty those of you who are graduating
today will have careers that last for a
long time perhaps 50 years or even more
what innovations will occur and how will
the world change it is hard for us even
to foresee that what is possible to
foresee however is that many of those
innovations and many of those changes
will come from business because the
story of the modern world in many ways
is the story of advances in technology
and trade and communication brought
about by private enterprise it is the
fact that those advances have led to
dramatic increases in human living
standards standards that is what makes
business a noble enterprise what is also
possible to foresee is that as today's
graduates you will be in position to
help shape and guide the changes that do
occur and you will do so at a time when
people are questioning whether business
can be relied upon whether the
innovations and the changes of the next
50 years will ensure inclusive
opportunity dignity of work and shared
rewards you will have an obligation as
business leaders to help answer these
questions affirmatively
and to help guide changes in the world
responsibly you will be well prepared
years ago Laura Ingalls journeyed to the
American frontier she went in a covered
wagon
most of you came here by airplane but in
a sense you made a similar journey you
journeyed to a modern frontier of
knowledge and discovery
you've taken classes you've studied
together you've learned from
extraordinary faculty and leaders
you've traveled on global study trips
made friends from around the world heard
their stories and created new ones in a
short time you will be Stanford
graduates and we will walk out onto the
GSB campus in the break California Sun
to celebrate but what you have learned
and the relationships you have formed
will stay with you as alumni do your
part to keep the GSB strong stay close
to your classmates return the calls of
other alumni provide the help to future
students that you have received from
those that preceded you as our
representatives in the world
I am confident you will be leaders who
act with courage with empathy and with
responsibility I am excited to see what
you accomplished and how your influence
will ripple outward in the world I know
you will make everyone here today and
all of us at the GSB very proud
congratulations class of 2018
and now it is my great pleasure to
introduce Carlos Brito
Carlos Brito came to Stanford from
Brazil and he graduated in 1989 with an
MBA he has made extraordinary
contributions as a business leader Brito
is known for his business acumen his
clarity of focus and his vision of
building a company that inspires pride
in his employees his customers and their
communities he has made bold strategic
moves to grow a B InBev into the world's
largest Brewing Company and one of the
world's top five consumer products
companies the company employs nearly
200,000 people in more than 50 countries
if you've had a Budweiser a Corona or a
Stella Artois those are just three of
the 500 brands owned by ABM dev what the
numbers do not convey is Britta's
ability to bring together people from
very different cultures and proud
traditions just try to imagine bringing
new ideas of that beer to st. Louis or
to Mexico or to Belgium or to Germany or
to Canada or to Australia
Brito has paired business strategy with
a focus on investing in corporate
culture and to connecting to customers
in their communities he sets this tone
personally and through his company's
policies his commitment to use renewable
energy and to support diversity
initiatives are salient examples of
Britos vision of a sustainable future it
is my great pleasure to welcome Carlos
Trudeau back to Stanford
[Applause]
good afternoon everyone
good afternoon the 11 did emeritus Joss
fellow members of the Stanford board of
trustees and the GSB Advisory Council
distinguished faculty and administration
thank you for having me here today it's
always a pleasure to be back at the
Stanford GSB I can't believe it's been
almost 30 years since I graduated I
remember sitting with my classmates
I remember hearing our commencement
speaker I do not however remember a
single word that person said so just in
case any of you following my footsteps
I'll start with the most important part
congratulations to the class of 2018
I also want to acknowledge a few very
special people in the audience in 1989
my parents were not able to come from
Brazil for my graduation well they are
here today alongside my wife Belinda and
my four kids
so the special moments like these
there's nothing better than being
surrounded by people you love most I'm
sure it's a feeling I share with so many
of you right now so before I really get
started please join me in giving a big
round of applause to all the parents
family and friends of the class of 2018
now about ten years ago I was giving a
talk no I don't like this one only I was
dressed very differently and there were
not nearly as many people instead the
audience was a group of trainees Global
trainees from our company ABM have I
gave my talk I did some QA
I said well time for one last question
and that's when his hands shut up I said
what's your name just said Ludmila from
Ukraine
okay Ludmilla what's your question Brito
what would the world miss if our company
did not exist I was like holy cow
and then I did what you do when you need
more time they said what's your name
again
thinking why are you from again
Thank You Kiev
well I've been to Kiev beautiful city
thinking finally I said them that my
colleagues and I would miss our company
culture and that our consumers would
miss our brands but later I came to my
top people and said guys made to think
more about this one class of 2018 you
leave this campus prepared to succeed
but you didn't come to place like
Stanford just to be successful you came
here because you want to be exceptional
so as you begin the next chapter I want
to challenge you with a question that
probably never came up in class a
version of the question I was asked
about the decade ago and that is what
would the world miss if you did not
exist I don't mean that literally of
course
every one of you is tremendously
tremendously talented and surrounded by
people who care about you I posed this
question in a global context why is
humanity better off because you are here
no matter what field you enter tackling
this question is going to be one of the
most important things you ever do what I
like to do is suggest a few ways of
approach in the world simple habits I
learned at this university and
throughout my career that can help you
address this question I'll begin by
telling you about how I I arrived here I
was the only Brazilian accepted to this
Stanford GSB in my ear I badly wanted to
come only one problem I couldn't afford
it but I knew there was a businessman in
Brazil who owned an investment bank and
sometimes gave loans to his employees
hoping to get MBAs abroad I was able to
meet him
I was not one of his employees but still
I made my case and this businessman
Georgia agreed to give me a scholarship
for my first year not from his bank but
from his personal account
I said Georgia I won't be able to pay
you back anytime soon he said no no I
don't want you to pay me back I want
just three things one keeping for me
keep me informed about your classes in
your progress to help somebody in the
future the way I'm helping you and three
before you accept a full-time job offer
come talk to me fast forward two years I
graduated Stanford with seven or eight
job offers like everybody else in my
class they were all on fancy letterhead
my salary training period bonus
everything right in front of me but I
had made a promise to talk to Georgia
and he also made me an offer
accept his offer was made over the phone
no paper no fancy letterhead and here
was the offer he got ready moved back to
Brazil by the time when nobody wanted to
do that and everybody wanted to be in
the US or Europe accept the job without
knowing the job description and take a
pay cut of around 80 percent compared to
my dad's offer so that didn't make sense
except for the fact that at the time
when Georgia decided to sponsor my first
year he also invited me to come for a
two-week internship where I met his
partners and learned about his business
and more importantly about the culture
at his bank this people were very
different than people at other companies
where I had worked before that left me
with the deep appreciation for the
quality of his partner's their values
and how fast-paced the place was the
was a place I could see myself be not
just for two or three years but for a
long time so I decided to bet on Georgia
I took his offer my dad almost killed me
and that was before he found out about
the eighty percent pay cut 29 years
later Georgia Paula lemon is one of the
world's most successful business leaders
and I'm still the same company where
accepted that first offer just a much
bigger company graduates throughout your
life you have the chance to bet them job
titles on salaries on job offers and
fancy letterhead here's my advice don't
bet on things
baton people instead join people you
admire you respect people that inspire
you with whom you share the same values
and from whom you can learn you'll never
regret it as my former professor here at
the GSB Jim Collins would say first who
than what my second piece of advice also
begins with something I learned here at
Stanford see growing up
I was used to being top of my class then
I got here and there were people from
all over the world and guess what they
were all at the top of their classes too
and I was intimidated to participate in
Kay's discussions because I was not a
native English speaker in language was a
barrier but by the second quarter I
learned how to deal with it a little bit
better then by the second year I started
to talk I started to think hey I can do
this getting through the GSB was not
impossible it was just really hard I
later realized that that place not
impossible just really hard turns out to
be the best place you can be because
that place not impossible just really
hard takes you out of your comfort zone
human beings can learn only so many
things each day
if you stay too long with it within your
comfort zone you fall into some sort of
routine and your learning curve flattens
if you go ten years without learning
anything you'll be able to learn ten
times as much in year eleven to
compensate it doesn't work quite like
that a good way to think about this is
the high jump if the bars never moved
higher there's no reason for anyone to
perform at a higher level as the bars
pushed higher we have to improve to
remain competitive by being challenged
we all learn more about ourselves about
our inner potential and about what we
can realize we live only once and it's a
waste to go through life without ever
realizing one one's full potential the
way to learn about your potential and
put it to work is to remain challenged
and stretched in other words you cannot
let yourself be too comfortable for too
long push yourself off out of that
situation into a not impossible just
really hard situation your learning
curve will against deepen and you'll
continue to grow as an individual and
professional my third and final piece of
advice is based on something I learned
at a conference 20 years ago this one
speaker was a renowned performance
psychologist and he was talking about
motivation in what drives people to
perform at their highest level his talk
was about your inner voice that allows
you to perform at levels that seemed
unattainable before here's what he said
imagine you have two tall buildings
someone puts a plank of wood between
them and says you get a million dollars
to cross that plank but if you fall you
die and now you probably say okay only
1% will fall but what if that 1% is me
mom no worth it
but what if instead your brother is up
there and he's about to fall off that
building and you need to cross that
plank to save him you're gonna cross
that plank your brother's life is a much
more powerful reason to perform in walk
the plank than the million dollars in
other words when the motivation was
about only you and the potential to make
a million dollars it was not strong
enough when the motivation was elevated
it now became about your brother and his
well-being that made all the difference
a higher-order motivation is not only
about you but about other people in the
world around you if you want to
accomplish something extraordinary a big
dream you have to choose that higher
order of motivation a motivation that's
strong and durable is essential if you
hope to perform at your highest level it
will give you the courage to take risks
it will give you the drive to overcome
naysayers or doubters and that's not all
a higher order of motivation will
provide you a North Star a reference
point that will get you down the right
path and make it easier for you to do
the right thing even when the right
thing is hard so as you enter this new
phase make sure you have a measure a
test that's bigger than just you for me
that test has always been the people
around me family friends colleagues at
work listen to this it's a great gift to
have people you care so much about that
you don't want to disappoint them
am i excited to tell them about my work
will they be proud of my decisions 10 or
20 years from now that's the kind of
motivation that lasts a lifetime and
it's the kind of motivation I hope
you'll all seek out which brings me back
to that auditorium 10 years ago in a
question I couldn't quite answer what
would the world miss if our company did
not exist
trying to tackle this question has
helped us become a better version of
ourselves we realized we should strive
to do more than just sell our products
we should be truly indispensable to our
customers consumers and to the
communities in which we operate that
mission that dream informs everything we
do today my point is simply that
thinking about this question ask
yourself why Humanity is better off
because you're here that will get you
motivated to go down the right path to
take the high road to do the right thing
and when people with your talent and
drive find that path when people like
you it's Drive not just to be successful
but exceptional it really does change
the world every day GSB alumni are
rebuilding new industries from the
ground up bringing new life to iconic
companies restoring our faith in public
service rethinking the way we fight
poverty eradicate disease combat climate
change and educate our kids today you
join them and if you bet on people as
the GSB and your parents have bet on you
if you strive to keep your learning
curve steep just as you have just as you
have over the last two years and
constantly seek out that higher
motivation like the long line of
graduates carry on the GSB tradition
then you too will leave your mark on the
world even if you don't remember a
single word your commencement speaker
said today so thank you again for this
honor and congratulations to the class
of 2018
[Applause]
it is now my great honor and pleasure to
introduce the GSB PhD class of 2018
our ph.d program is small and exclusive
with an admission rate well under 10%
these individuals came here as students
dedicating themselves to two or three
years of coursework followed by an
intensive research apprenticeship in
their chosen fields having become true
experts they leave us as colleagues
setting out on a path to create new
knowledge which we know will help change
the world of business and management for
the better today we formally celebrate
the transition of these individuals from
students to future intellectual leaders
after their advisors place the hood of
the Stanford Graduate School of Business
on them they will join us on the stage
as we welcome them as colleagues into
our profession Diane Lee the executive
director of the ph.d program will now
read their names and their dissertation
advisor will hood them
[Applause]
- ah-ah-ah Sava Dasha studies sources of
innovation and the choices established
firms researchers entrepreneurs and
venture capitalists make when pursuing
innovation Dmitri are can jet ski
[Applause]
dimitri studies causal inference methods
Matthew Steven Corot or Matthew studies
how organizational culture helps drive
innovation and high performance and
companies Jennifer Daniels Jennifer
studies how individuals perceive social
norms in small groups and teams
[Applause]
Nick do chenko Nick studies econometric
methods of causal inference with a
particular focus on the use of machine
learning methods and economics Kurt
Harris key current studies how companies
communicate financial information to
investors
Justin Huang Justin studies economic
incentives for content creators in
online platforms and marketplaces Arthur
J go
[Applause]
Arthur studies how organizations use
technology to signal values Jinyoung
hyung Jinyoung studies the interplay
between government policies and
international financial markets lu
xiaoning xiaoning studies patterns of
investment and incentives of
participants and collective investment
settings such as venture funding
evening ma Yi Ming studies the systemic
risk created when banks intermediate
loans on behalf of other banks Charlie
McClure Charlie studies how accounting
regulation affects firm decisions
[Applause]
Babak Moalem e Babak studies how
participants in online marketplaces
behave strategically Jim Wynn jewel
studies white-collar crime enforcement
and finds that the diversion of
government resources from traditional
criminal investigative priorities toward
counterterrorism after the 9/11
terrorist attacks led to a significant
increase in white-collar crime in the
years ahead of the Great Recession
James goon whoop cake
James studies how the market competition
affects the rate of innovation in the
semiconductor industry Carlos Adolfo
Sanchez Martinez
Carlos studies partisan discrimination
in court and he shows that individuals
who file employment lawsuits are
discriminated at trial according to the
employers partisanship Young Saeng young
studies scale of mutual funds and skill
of fund managers and shows a significant
mismatch between mutual fund skill and
scale Sara Stein Sara's studies culture
language and hiring
Elise tuck Elise studies how employees
performance and evaluations of their
performance are influenced by their
workplace environment such as the
quality of their peers or managers
Christina Zhu Christina studies the
effect of alternative data such as
satellite images and consumer
transaction data on the stock market and
on corporate managers Julian whose
lattice Julian studies when and why
people decide to volunteer and give
money to charity
[Applause]
this is the first class to graduate with
the new version of the certificate in
public management and social innovation
founded by the late dean emeritus RJ
Miller 45 years ago the certificate
program educates leaders who understand
societal issues designed for and
evaluate impact and understand the
specificities of the management of
social organizations both in the private
and public sectors today's certificate
graduates really do embody the spirit of
our GSB motto change lives change
organizations change the world and as
they'd like to add for the better they
participated in a wide range of Social
Innovation courses covering topics such
as healthcare innovation education
reform sustainable energy markets
poverty and inequality and leadership
and diversity they explored roles with
high social impact such as corporate
responsibility nonprofit board
governance philanthropy and civic
engagement they operated the GSB s
impact fund they travel to disadvantaged
places both in the United States and
abroad to take a deep dive into
entrenched social and environmental
issues and see for themselves how social
innovators address them some of these
students have developed their own social
enterprises and are ready to launch them
right upon graduation
this year we have 131 recipients of the
certificate their names are listed in
the commencement program I now ask the
students receiving the certificate to
stand and be recognized
congratulations
good afternoon on this festive and
beautiful day it is my pleasure as
director of the Stanford MSX program to
present this year's graduates who will
receive the degree of Master of Science
and management the mission of the MSX
program is to provide experienced
leaders men and women who have spent at
least eight years in professional and
management roles the opportunity to
prepare themselves for increasingly
senior positions and organizations they
will lead the program is a full-time
year-long course of academic study
giving these students an all-too-rare
chance for reflection and growth in the
midst of an already accomplished career
simultaneously they bring to the GSB a
perspective shaped by experience with
difficult organizational challenges
enriching our academic community as a
result while studying at Stanford
these students carry the title of Sloan
fellow a tradition that dates to the
year the program was founded in 1957
this year's 103 fellows came to Stanford
from across the United States and
thirty-one additional countries many are
sponsored by their employers others will
be joining or creating innovative new
enterprises after graduation having
completed all the academic requirements
of the program this year's graduating
fellows will join the worldwide family
of Stanford Business School alumni on
behalf of the administration of the
program and the faculty who have taught
them join me in wishing each of them
great fulfillment and success in the
next phase of their careers
now among the previous Dean's of the GSB
one is also a graduate of this program
in fact he is a graduate of all three
GSB programs that offer a degree today
Robert or Bob Joss began a Stanford
journey as a Sloan fellow in 1965 he
then graduated from the MBA program in
1967 and the ph.d program in 1970 like
our graduates he had an accomplished
career in business and government then
returned to the GSB as dean in 1999 for
an impressive decade of institution
building literally institution building
is this included the planning and
construction of the knight Management
Center in honor of Dean Joss's service
and dedication the top 10% of the MSX
class ranked by academic performance are
designated as Robert Joss scholars as we
read the names of the graduates we will
also announce if they have achieved the
distinction of Robert Shaw scholar it's
my pleasure now to read our graduates
names while Dean Levin presents the
diplomas Michael on
Daichi amake
Christina arbol ayahs per day not to
Baba Mohammed Ramzi Babji Jose bets in
Yanni Lindsey Morgan who Cheryl Kirsten
Nelson Johnson
Byron Matthias Carl Edward Joseph
Carroll
Clemence Joss Andre kesaji Neto
Jing Bao Shan Robert Josh scholar Mickey
Rachel shettrick Andrew li Chang
[Music]
[Applause]
John Hill Collins
Sarah
Catherine Craig Matthew grouchy
Robert Shaw scholar alvaro del Sol Luca
de Muro Garth Edwards
[Music]
been Elbaz david fool on
[Applause]
goooo Jinghua Ricardo Gutierrez Robert
just scholar Chang Myung hung schewe how
Robert Josh scholar Stephen James hey
more Daniel Herrmann
[Applause]
Ahmed Abdel Hamid Aneesh Andy Hoch house
[Music]
Aditi Joshi Gobi gamourai Edward carbo
Okoboji tarp guru carton a
[Applause]
david rowe cosa King bow Amit Kumar
Valentin Kootenai Soph soon on Guildford
law Robert Shaw scholar Andrew Lloyd
Luis jr. Don C on Lima Richard Cho hey
me lonsdorf Robin Lancelot Lumsden Jason
MA
Yima
[Applause]
year May Magali ice
Islam Mohammed Sayeed Mahdi
Yusuke ed Matsuda Bruno Manish
Ravindra nice tree
[Applause]
Deepak Mittal Robert Shaw scholar
Murillo Machado Maura
[Applause]
nons mulchand on e ma sakuni Nagaoka
Sheetal Mariani Anna never Oba Killian
O'Connor
jaunty Markby Anson olive Cooper Rahul
pelage Aaron pan
Jhon Park
[Applause]
Diego Jose banana PL grandia Roberto
Perez Ariana pitching in Dave Prakash
[Applause]
Satya deep Prasanna pune puri banchon
Ganesh Ramakrishnan nyan Romani new
Maratha Rastogi John Bishop Ravenel
Robert Shaw scholar Jalil Regis
Francisco Reynoso Annie Reilly
Alessandro Rinaldi Nicoletta rule
[Applause]
Madhavi Sahai
Smita syringe n oj sir oh he
Parul Sharma
so hey Chino Mia
[Applause]
Patrizia
Soriano emit Street hair on Robert Josh
scholar and Etan Robert Josh scholar 1f
Triola sample Robert Josh scholar died
um Pablo Jose Valenzuela masculine
Aaron ban bore
mike van Wyk Teodoro
my neck David Marcus bulls Mandeep Singh
Warrick
Sonny em web Erica misako Welch Ryan
O'Melveny Wilson near Yahav
nobo hiko yamamoto
yi yang angel Zukowski in chi chow
Veronica ciao
[Applause]
among the Robert L Joss scholars one
student's academic achievements places
them at the top of the MSX class this
student is awarded the George G C Parker
Prize named in honor of GSB faculty and
former program director George Parker
the graduate receives a certificate a
cash award and the name will be on a
plaque displayed at the GSB the
recipient of the 2018 jouji see Parker
prize is soon on Guilford law
[Applause]
[Music]
distinguished guests faculty members
staff families and friends the MBA
students gathered before us today have
engaged in a transformational experience
they've acquired solid foundation in
general management and have pursued
deeper study in their areas of interest
they have engaged in personal growth and
built relationships that will last a
lifetime
they have helped the school and the
community in many ways they are an
impressive group and are ready and
worthy to join the ranks of our
illustrious alumni therefore it is my
great honor and privilege to present to
you the Stanford MBA class of 2018
as you leave I hope your memories of the
GSB will remain fresh and that you will
stay involved with the school
our alumni played an important role in
your academic experience ranging from
serving as judges in the executive
challenge to acting as mentors in
intrapreneurial courses it is my wish
that you too will engage with the GSB
academic mission as alumni and give your
time and experience generously to future
classes your class has already
demonstrated its desire to stay
connected to the GSB and to support the
school in a meaningful way through your
participation in the class gift campaign
you will leave your own legacy and play
a part in bringing the GSB experience to
future generations as other alumni have
done before you at this time I would
like to ask the members of the Student
Association Senate and the members of
the SA committees to stand
[Applause]
these are the elected leaders of the
student body the SA has a profound
impact on the academic extracurricular
and social lives of students and serves
as an important conduit between students
faculty and staff serving on the SA is a
tremendous amount of work and is the
foundation for much of the students
experience please join me in another
round of applause for this committed
[Music]
[Applause]
now I will ask the al-bakr leadership
fellows to stand
the Arbuckle leadership Fellows Program
plays an integral role in the GSB
leadership curriculum by bringing
together second year students to support
the leadership development of the first
year class on behalf of the school I
thank these seventy students for the
tireless work and dedication please join
me in another round of applause
I would not like to ask the student
leaders of study trips global seminars
and the Stanford Chinua exchange program
to stand
these 92 outstanding student leaders
partnered with the school on a critical
component of the GSB education the
global experience requirement they
served as peer educator for more than
600 students traveling to 24 countries
helping them discover how business
skills are relevant in a wide variety of
industries institution and context for
acting as ambassadors of the GSB and for
their indelible impact on the students
they led we thank them please join me in
another round of applause
in the next few minutes we will begin
reading the names of the graduates in
alphabetical order and we will invite
them forward to receive their diploma
names will be read by Margit Hayes
assistant dean of the MBA program and by
Kirsten Moss assistant dean of MBA
admissions and financial aid graduates
will receive their diplomas from the
eleven all of you here have undoubtedly
heard of RJ Miller RJ RJ served in the
US Air Force during the Second World War
and was later once one of the so-called
whiz kids who revolutionized the Ford
Motor Company r.j. became president of
Ford and then later the much admired
fourth Dean at the GSB from 1968 to 1978
his sterling leadership of the school is
legendary and he remained involved with
the school and his passing at the age of
101 last November in honor of Dean
Miller's service the top 10% of the
class ranked by academic performance are
designated as RJ Miller scholar
as we read the names of the graduates we
will also announce if they have achieved
the distinction of RJ Miller scholar
in the case of John degrees students who
are walking today but not graduating we
will identify those who are currently in
the top 10% of their class Margaret and
Kirsten would you please begin
Laura obeah
Laurence Jeffrey Abraham
Eddie Ackerman Rebecca winter Ackerman
Tolu Lotte a De Aza Ruth a do doc Oh
Matthew Allen a li Animesh Agrawal RJ
Miller scholar
a Luba Shagun Ajay
Daniel aqua Carranza
Sara Oh Bona Adam Alcock Stefan our talk
[Music]
subo me eluc Oh Catherine Alvarez tirado
Okara on Doc you chef Mukesh Ambani
Dhruv Ameen yen and
in the old Anderson Kaelin Charles
angered Marissa Rachel ash by Issa as
fat Djuka Avellino Alex Avery
Jeremy David Cooperman avens RJ Miller
scholar
no a you
[Applause]
antonio Beza Jessica Kathleen Olivier
buyer Nicole by on Landa Chuck Barrett
RJ Miller scholar
Kathryn barrows RT M bar sykov
[Applause]
bizarre bizarre in Louie Padron
and Gardner Bell Tobin Binion Vasundhara
/ Gotha
[Music]
Lauren Elizabeth Blake RJ Miller scholar
Jordan Andrew blasek Steven Philip Blanc
RJ Miller scholar
Natalie Boddington Erin deal booth
Jason Bornstein
[Applause]
[Music]
Blanka bolete Bensel Charles I'm
Bradford Ashley Jane brazier Alex Justin
Ratman RJ Miller scholar
Tatyana Brezina David Marquette Brooks
Jeremy a brown Luke Carol brown
Janna Marian bubbly Jessie Buckingham
[Applause]
Jonathan embolic Brian Larson Butler
Thomas Callahan
Ryan Calvert
Thomas a Campbell
[Applause]
Evan Cantor Mark Bryant Cassidy I'm say
Catholic Celine Shalu
Trisha Chandi Romani Patrick Abbot chase
Laura Cho
Stella binging Chen Shalu and RJ Miller
scholar
shoptaw who might see guru body lime
Choi
[Applause]
fernanda causa
Nataly Ashcroft Clark
[Applause]
Scot Cleveland
ro Ito and Marion cone Henry Cole cake
coming
[Applause]
Yan Contreras Ortiz
Deanna Corona Danny Cotter
[Music]
[Applause]
Stephen James Crawford Albert G and
Reese we
[Applause]
Stephen Zimmerman
Madeline Dangerfield sha sha la - Neely
Devon T Davis
Lisa Dora played the smae that came out
wrong josé Luiz de latina Elizondo
David and rude Emrys Hollander boss
[Music]
but team at deco
tamdan RJ Miller scholar
Natalie knock doe far shift on to potty
[Applause]
Matt Doty
Katie Michele dove annalisa tragic RJ
Miller scholar
Brian Thomas Dudley Caroline Reed Duffy
[Music]
Jason Dunford Lauren Dunford Aisha a
dupe Avanti
Yasmine L Bailey Kyle Engelmann RJ
Miller scholar
Savannah gene English Matthew Allen and
Tobin
[Applause]
[Music]
Begum aired on Paulo Mariota Mariah's
Macedo Laura Rose fair Jake Felner
[Applause]
jaesi Fisher
Claire Louise Fisher
David Fisher
Marshall Fisher
[Applause]
Peyman bruja
Andrew Philip Fowler
[Applause]
Michael Phu
Arnaldo Gabaldon Nicholas cachero Billy
Gallagher Diego Galvez database
NAT garden swartz flora Gautier Maria
gavrillac Robert Stewart George
Joseph go Brio RJ Miller scholar
Lucas Giannini's Mendoza Abreu
Dana mark Gingrich
[Applause]
John go back
John get hurt
RJ Miller scholar Becca goldstein
[Applause]
Alberto goatse
Jill Greenberg Margaret Jasper Greenberg
Joshua Ryan Tim baaga Griffin
[Applause]
Christina whoa
Comanche Gupta
[Music]
[Applause]
rish Gupta RJ Miller scholar
sadhna Gupta jihad Hazuki
[Applause]
wen Han
Tyler punished
[Music]
[Applause]
Adam Gordon hen Oh Paulie
Muraki Jeff how Anna ho
[Applause]
Catherine Elizabeth Susan Hayes George
John Jordan Thomas Aquinas Hayward
[Applause]
Connor Edwin heard Robert J helbling
[Music]
[Applause]
William Douglas Morris helfen Charles
Henrickson
ray Hernandez
[Applause]
Sara
[Music]
[Applause]
Sara and think this RJ Miller scholar
Michael Joseph Dean's Hobbs
Supriya Hobbs RJ Miller scholar
Yuni hope Ryan Scott Hollander
[Applause]
Megan Holston Alexander
[Music]
Jessica Fulton Hanna Hanzel Zachary
horrid
[Music]
[Applause]
Dayna Xiao Xiao ho
Ryan Nicholas Houston RJ Miller scholar
G ha wine
[Applause]
Benjamin Hughes RJ Miller scholar
Lauren Humphrey Charles Huey one yet see
[Applause]
Scott Michael things
Samuel Alexander Berg Jackson Paita
Johnson
Benjamin Jones Candice Paige Jones
Matthew Jones
[Applause]
Matthew calorie oh I'm sorry
Andrew kaha Larry
[Applause]
Magdelena
Karla RJ Miller scholar
Jennifer Victoria Kamara Michael Jason
Pat sir
[Applause]
Hector key RJ Miller scholar
Geordi healin Carolyn Marie Kelly
Devon Michael Kelsey Amanda Carol Kent
Mallika handle whoa
mark David Kannan
yeah yeah kocha
[Applause]
James Kim RJ Miller scholar Satara
potala Shirin crawl multi creamer
[Applause]
[Music]
Matthew James creme er Sonny Kumar
kristinia LaMarca
Eric Xavier lakin Nathan lamb Olivia
Pope lang
Naomi yoshinari Laporte Justin Larkin
Cristobal alcalde layout Benjamin
Patrick Lee Edward Lee
[Applause]
Nicholas done lepre
Jeffrey Allen Livia
Nora Leoben
[Applause]
Anthony de Barros link Kari Whitman
Sharon Lowenstein Thomas lost us
[Applause]
Benji Loney where's Lewis
Jeff lion David ma shalyah MD ma
[Applause]
aiming my RJ Miller scholar
Maria
Alexandra Christina Rufino Maceda Jamie
McFarland sir be Maheshwari
Arthur Martin's Costa Malcolm George
Malkin
Timmy mal
[Applause]
Natasha Multani
who named mod via RJ Miller scholar
Carlos my nati
Nikolas Marino Danielle
Jacqueline Marshak RJ Miller scholar
Andrew Martin Cristina Martinez Lauren
our Leigh Martinez Jack Marzulli RJ
Miller scholar
Kelsey Mason
[Applause]
Carlota Matthew
Caroline Matthews Ryan James McGuigan
Vincent Paul mcphillip Jen McPhillips
[Applause]
me here meta name it meta
MD may take
[Applause]
Michael James melody Alexander Menke
Sophia Messier Arriola Robbie Michnik RJ
Miller scholar
Brian Alamo Carew
[Music]
JV Manu Andrew more
Ted Murphy
[Applause]
Sushma thought in the new room Cameron
naps
Nicholas Naranjo Raphael see me on the
top
[Applause]
Mike Nara
so me I can get to me
[Applause]
Aaron Newman Robert Hardy Newell RJ
Miller scholar
Michelle when Tim Nichols and rude know
[Applause]
Agnes 10 de manera Omega Diego on Tamara
Benavides Itamar or or trigger
Olivia pop-up
John Leavitt paradise
Joshua McKinstry Parrish
[Applause]
Jenny common park
Sola Park
ah kaleesh party party
[Applause]
Jamie Patrick Theo
Michael Pat salos Fox Robin Pirani
Karolina Perez marcelina Perez Daniel
pets
[Applause]
Deanna Danielle P Annabelle Pookie
Barbara Wilson Cova Marcin Pokhara chef
Sookie
[Applause]
Kaitlyn Rebecca Pomeroy
Stu paws lands RJ Miller scholar John
Powell RJ Miller scholar
rushan Prakash Shaniqua deuce
Sara ramen Nikolas Ryan resinous Taylor
ray Megan Elizabeth Raymond Lee Morris
read the third
Toby writes RJ Miller scholar
chase Elliott Richard max Richards
[Music]
[Applause]
a Tony mo wreath Cole Gloria reso Elias
Jordan Scott Ridenhour Habib
miss Kayla
[Applause]
Annie Robertson RJ Miller scholar
Manuel Romero Bruno Russa Rosa Adam
Rosenthal RJ Miller scholar
Benjamin rau Martin Rudy GA Josephine
Ruiz Helie Lee over you
[Applause]
just insanity
[Music]
Anthony Salamone Kate summer dick Neha
some Daria Aaron else annuals
Robert chauffeurs aniele's Anna Martin's
least nur Ali Schmidt
Patrick Williams Nick
[Applause]
Chelsey's shut
Eric Nathaniel Schreiber Christopher
Schwartz
Tomer Schwartz
[Applause]
Joseph tanner Scott
Steph Scott
Stephanie Morgan Scott
Dhruva Shah
Cooney Nitin Shah
RJ Miller scholar
ruchi or shot
[Applause]
Sejal Nunda Kumar Shah Brittany Shah
Archie chef Shaw
Angela she Audrey she Jacob Schiff
[Applause]
surrender sing
Karen Sinha
[Applause]
Nikolas Sinton on
so Hail Caesar
Michael Austin Schneider
Nicholas a soraka kelly elizabeth soul
[Applause]
[Music]
Andrew sparks michael barratt speaker
[Applause]
Maxwell spear
Ignacio Spinney ACK
Peter Spradling Naveen Srivatsa
[Applause]
Aaron stommer Annie Stan cliff Jessica
Stephan's
Brianna Stein Risa Danielle lair Stein
[Applause]
deny staring tall
Stephanie Rose Stillman
[Applause]
Matthew R Strauss RJ Miller scholar
Andrew Collins Stutz
[Applause]
Carroll
Peter Sullivan
[Music]
Emily Sunderland RJ Miller scholar
Shrishti Sundaram
[Applause]
lauren renee schwartz
meesa T'Challa Naoki Takeda Jessica
Talbert
Yin Tong
[Applause]
Ryota Tashi
Iman Taylor Lindsay
[Applause]
Matthew Tessar Freud Polina Toba DRL Dan
Tom tram
Derrick soy
[Applause]
John Randall Tyson
[Music]
Zachary Ola Carlos Manuel Oh Peggy
Acharya
[Music]
Sophia Valencia Taurus Camille Van Horn
Nina
Dawson
[Applause]
Anika Mary Verghese
William Anthony Vernon RJ Miller scholar
[Applause]
Jennifer via top 10% of current class
with virgin Downey
[Applause]
tibia fish wanna go sing Ling Manuel
Venki
Anthony what gotcha
Samantha pocketing way Rachel Wallach
van poor time
Frances where wine
[Applause]
Rebecca Boyd Weidler Ali Weiner
Catherine Benner Weinmann Evelyn den
heart Weiss
Megan Welch
read Westwood
[Applause]
Paley white
Forrest Wilkinson RJ Miller scholar
Tom wait a sec
dan whoo doh whoo Jennifer Shaw Michael
yaki MA Michael M yang RJ Miller scholar
Matthew Yoder
[Applause]
Joe yuan
Marcello's Zambrano Orlando Raphael
Zambrano Katherine Jane Zealand Peng
Zhang joy Zhang
Tong Zhong
[Music]
Sophia Jung
[Applause]
Cecelia Joe
[Music]
Cindy zoo
Yulin zu e Shuang
Helen though
[Applause]
nominated and chosen by their peers the
recipient of the Ernest C Arbuckle award
is the second year MBA student who by
their active participation initiative
leadership and personal integrity his
judged as having contributed the most to
the fulfillment of the goals of the
Stanford Graduate School of Business in
their actions both within the school and
in society we are delighted to have
Susan Arbuckle the daughter of Ernie
Arbuckle with us today to deliver the
award the recipient receives a cash
prize and also has their name on a
plaque on display at the GSB this year's
recipient of the award is Celine
Shalhoub
[Applause]
[Music]
the Alexander a robber check student
achievement award in finance was
established to honor professor Robert
Jack's outstanding contribution to the
teaching of finance at the Stanford
Graduate School of Business from 1960
until his death in 1978 the award is
given to an MBA student selected by the
finance faculty for outstanding
achievement in the finance courses the
recipient receives the award and also
has their name on a plaque on display at
the GSB this year's recipient of the
award is Robby Michnik
[Music]
[Applause]
among the RJ Miller scholar is one
student's academic achievement places
them at the top of the class this
student is designated as the henry ford
ii scholar and receives along with the
miller scholar scroll a cash award and
the name on a plaque displayed at the
GSB this year recipient of the award is
Jack Missoula
[Applause]
[Music]
honored guests faculty staff families
and friends we have reached the
conclusion of our ceremony I invite you
to join us for receptions at the Nate
Management Center graduates please stand
[Applause]
what a journey it has been
congratulations graduates you are now
alumni or will be tomorrow morning
alumni of the Stanford Graduate School
of Business
[Applause]
[Music]